In this lecture, we discuss
the simplest nontrivial
stochastic process, the
Bernoulli process.
Time is divided into slots.
At each slot, we have
an independent trial
such as a coin flip.
And each trial results
in heads or tails.
Or in different language, each
trial may or may not result in
an arrival or a success.
Pretty much everything we
will do will be a simple
application of skills that
we already have.
For example, we already know
that the number of arrivals in
n time slots is described
by the binomial PMF.
We will then discuss some
consequences of the
independence of the
different trials.
Basically, the process
has no memory.
Whatever happens in the future
is not affected by whatever
happened in the past.
By exploiting this property, we
will find the distribution
of the time of the first arrival
and more generally of
the time of the kth arrival.
We will also find the
distribution of the time
between consecutive arrivals.
Next, we will take two
independent Bernoulli
processes, let's say arrivals of
men and arrivals of women,
and merge them to get an overall
arrival process.
We will see that the
merged process is
also a Bernoulli process.
We will also look at the reverse
operation, namely,
splitting a Bernoulli process
into two separate processes.
Finally, we will look at a
particular asymptotic regime
in which we have a large number
of time slots but a
very small probability of an
arrival during each time slot.
We will carry out some algebraic
manipulations.
And we will see that the
binomial PMF for the number of
arrivals can be well
approximated by the so-called
Poisson PMF.